if you've been a Broadway star for many  years if you've been a longtime motion  picture actress if you carried also your  own television series I think you're  entitled to extra consideration and  therefore I respectfully present that  distinguished old trooper and Academy  Award winner Miss Patti  Thank You mr. lemon and now the award  for the best performance given by a  supporting actor and the nominated are  Nick Adams in twilight of Honor Bobby  Darin in captain Newman MD Melvyn  Douglas in heart Hugh Griffith in Tom  Jones and John Huston in the Cardinal  winner is  accepting for mr. Melvin Douglas Brandon  du Helder  mr. Douglas is in Spain and he wished me  to thank the members of the Academy and  his fellow actors and the entire group  that was on HUD for this on it thank  you